gender u-pen swimmer leah thomas wins
the 100-meter and 200-meter freestyle
races against harvard
days after usa swimming said it would
release new policy on whether elite
trans
athletes will be able to compete against
biological women
so what what is your take on that
i've had conversations like this with
multiple people and it's like
there's
in my opinion there's like no like
definitive answer
because it's
it's hard
to
say to someone like
okay you identify as woman but no you're
not
and
it's
it's difficult because of just like i
was saying earlier genetics like i
someone could say i identify as woman
but physically your body
is not
identifying as women because of just how
you were born and there's just
things that
contribute to you
being what you were before you transit
transgender to a woman that
puts you head and shoulders over women
like we were saying earlier just
genetics and so
it's
it's difficult to be like no you can't
do it i think it'd be really easy for me
to say no
it would actually be like really easy
because here's here's my my my take on
it we work so hard yeah i have worked
like so incredibly hard to get to the
point where i am in like i'm i'm more of
a volleyball player right yeah so
to me
the idea of we we have such a small pie
anyway is there money in women's sports
and i've worked so hard and i see the
contracts that are out there for girls
better than me
and they're not making anything and
they're way better than me
so
to me it's like disrespectful to women
to like take away the little opportunity
we have in sports
what do you what do you think about that
statement
uh
it is uh
you don't have to try it carefully no
it's it's just like it's
this this topic it's just
difficult to have for me to have like a
like be like yes no because
i don't want to
disrespect anybody and their life and
how they uh
well but it's not about what they think
it's about like what do you like what's
right what's fair
yeah and
i've said like well maybe they should um
in athletics put like a
number of how much testosterone you can
have in your system how much estrogen
you can have in your system but then
that would
count out the women who are born with
more testosterone naturally who
are born women and
it's
it's hard and it's it puts
in physical contact sports because i've
played against
a transgender woman and and i've had
friends who played against transgender
women and it
puts us in like a
you've played it again oh that never
happened to me actually when my second
year of college i played against a
transgender woman and then i had a
friend this past actually last year she
was in a tuesday night basketball league
and she played against a transgender
woman and
physically it's like she was telling me
like why is this person like bulldozing
me over i'm not like a small person i
come i can body someone on defense but
this woman that she was playing a plane
against was just knocking her over and
she found out that she was a trans woman
and
it's
in a sense like sometimes dangerous in
contact sports to be playing against a
transgender woman because if you play
against
a man they're going to be just it's just
naturally like physical right because
right that's who they are and so
there's a different like physicality
when it comes from
women to men and i just think when it
comes to physical sports
it's a little bit more like
safety right so so
it's funny because
it sounds like you're saying it's not
fair
and you agree with me but it's almost
like there's a part of you that doesn't
want to admit it because you don't want
to like offend trans people it's not
that i don't want to offend it's like
i
because if we don't speak up for
ourselves like you will
yeah that is true like and that's what
we're seeing now like we can't speak up
for ourselves people are afraid to
offend that community because they're
very loud
but it like to me this is this is like
um the the transgender
woman or woman that like won that race
that that is so disrespectful to the
women that worked their whole lives
and you know how little opportunity like
like we get four years in college
everyone i know that's played says
college is the best four years you're
going to play yeah you get the community
like even coming overseas it's just not
it's do you think it's the same i don't
think it's this it's different it really
is different and even um talking to the
girls that play pro they all like told
me
well the you know the one or two i asked
that they preferred college and i've
talked to girls from my colleague
everyone says college and so that's a
moment that
the girl that got second third whatever
they're never gonna get that back yeah
and
i just feel like if we as athletes can't
stand up for ourselves like who who will
yeah that's true and
i can understand that because i would be
upset if i was
in a position to and i was in college in
a position to go play on a pro team
overseas and then
um a transgender woman comes onto the
team
and they're out there dunking doing
everything bodying people and i'm like
i i physically can't do that right
limits like i physically i cannot do
that i can train i can train to where i
get hops and i can dunk and i can body
people but it's like i have to
physically train whether and it's this
person that has it because they were
born with it and so
it's
it's difficult because it's like i think
that there should be
more caution when it comes to it but i
also don't want to be like
no like
like you can't
so if there was a law that came forward
and said it's biological men biological
women there's no in between would you be
against that
we're talking about politics now bro we
bring a politics
it's not political it could be a college
like rule i guess right yeah
uh
i i probably wouldn't be against it it
would suck because it would essentially
be taking away the opportunity for
whoever to be able to participate in the
way they identified
um
i don't know maybe
for
in the future they have certain teams
that like are just like trans male or
trans women to where that
this like isn't a problem or in a sense
well i would be okay if you know there
was some league that was co-ed where
even in you know colleges or whatever
like
certain amount of men's biological men
certain amount of biological women so
they can compete in something yeah but
i
i keep seeing these like trans
men competing in the women's division
and just
annihilating everybody yeah
and i i've never actually been in a
position where i played against somebody
but it boils my blood because i i've
worked so hard
to get to this point where i have
very little up like
i think if i got a pro contract i would
get free housing
and maybe 10 000 like for the whole nine
months
that's that's like that's not
something
i don't know how it is in basketball
because no clue but the
um even the girls i was talking to
they're wit like
way better than me and they don't get
they maybe get 15. wow well i don't not
the i don't know the girls on the lions
like i didn't ask them the money but i
mean like the pro girls that i know yeah
um and it's just it's funny because i
feel like you agree with me but you just
really don't want to offend that
community it's not that i don't want to
offend them it's like for me i
i see where you're coming from and
i
i see both sides like i understand
their
side i understand your side is just like
i'm just in the middle it's like a happy
medium
so like i understand both sides but i
don't want to
take a side
not take a side by
it i don't i don't know
i just and not though i don't want to
take a side it's like i understand both
and i understand the
the value in both
it's like
okay so if there was a rule that they
said
trans women are allowed
like they can anyone can identify as
trans and as long as they're on estrogen
for a year they can play it doesn't
matter if they're six ten it doesn't
matter like anyone would you
support that rule
i would i would probably be like upset
and frustrated
because of just what we've been talking
about and so um
so no yeah no i probably wouldn't it'd
be
it'd be difficult like even if they
like did it i would so welcome that
person in but it would be
a little bit like
hard to be like
and like i want to clarify i don't have
any problem like do it with you know
what they do like with their bodies yeah
right yeah i'm horse i'm i'm nice you
know what i mean i'm a chit chatter yeah
i'm friendly
i won't remember most people's names but
i'll talk to them
[Laughter]
but um i just i think
you know as athletes we kind of have to
have these
conversations and
like it seems like most girls i talk to
agree with me but also don't you know
we're agreeable i think like most women
are more agreeable do you know what
agreeable means yeah yeah yeah than men
so i think we don't like the idea of
like excluding somebody